hello good afternoon we're back Joey
hello like we never went away 24 hours
ago yesterday right here so of course as
I mentioned yesterday there's that can
only really mean one of two things which
means the Halloween event if you guys
didn't know already is out there is
Cthulhu zenyatta I think I need that
skin in my life yeah but yeah basically
a bunch of new skins Junkin Stein's back
we can talk about some of those changes
in a second but why don't we show some
of the skins off yeah then I think I'm
gonna I'm gonna make everyone wait I
think we're gonna show all the skins we
are gonna open loop crates of course
obviously we're on twitch YouTube
GameSpot maybe periscope as well start
showing off the piracy like this one
fires pretty good pirate Nana
with a little parakeet or parent you got
parent repair okay so we'll go into the
event we'll play a little bit and then
we'll open his 52 loot boxes I think
yeah so I got a free one played junket
says revenge got another one and then
have 50 extras nice always good so well
it's a little glare that is wow that's
weird cool but weird alright what else
we got there's a bunch right yeah this
is a good amount see who else was on
there oh macri's yeah he's got the van
helsing yeah the arms cool I'm diggin
that this going looks really nice though
okay it's a nice detail very good maybe
it did the the old skins obviously came
back to you right so like did they did
the witch like can you buy them then you
buy them now Oh looks like yeah they
were hidden before right well you can
abide them before right yeah pretty sure
yeah so you can buy like I already have
hers the ones I don't have
what's up Callum Anderson I'll be
checking chat with you guys while Joey
plays
so if you have questions or and whatnot
that looks cool I like the macula I
think I think it could use a little bit
more like some of these skins as we go
through them I don't feel like there's
as much going on to them I mean there's
some subtle touches here the mass is
different obviously guns were slightly
different but like some have like crazy
ones like this wanted truth like some
mattress John we've made a good point it
reminds it does have the dragon
aesthetic but it does also remind me of
Kerrigan quite a bit right well you know
I'm sorry aft - I like her like her
skirt here with the wings yeah that's
nice she finally got a pretty cool I
mean I've liked some of her other ones
but that one's really cool yeah his is
pretty good too like yes
you know fitting if anything I would
expect yeah his shield spins that's cool
Oh actually let's look at symmetric gun
oh my god this thing is insane it's the
same with those I feel like with
zenyatta as the balls that he shoots -
it's because it's got the Cthulhu thing
you'll see in a second yeah zombie
slayer eight one three I remember the
stream from last year cool got a return
Halloween event I already bought this
you bought it yeah we straight go I
couldn't I couldn't resist what did you
get the dude that's fine Neal hey
over-under that he gets this I bet you
he gets this III you deserve it you
deserve to be punished plenty of money
it's necessary you deserve to be
punished for it although they said that
like dupes are a lot harder to get now
right yeah so I guess it that won't
happen
good I'm living in the past home let me
let me take off the gold oh is that why
okay that's a trick man in our in our
skins video you have the golden version
made me think it was a gold so cool the
gold one looks cooler though okay I'll
be back oh look at that anyways Zenyatta
my boy Nutcracker is pretty good but
colt is one though look at that koltes
in yatta and then if you look at the
the balls later it's got the I so remind
me a lot of Seaton or C'thun yeah C'thun
but see dude with Cthulhu but Seaton was
a boss in World of Warcraft and he had
the eyeballs that was the thing right I
was beginning so I think that's pretty
cool I that's the one I think I
personally want the most but it's
because it's a character I play yeah so
it's like that's kind of how it goes
dude lucio didn't get one no there's
only a few emotes - it seems like
there's not that many yes stop Mike
Kelly who was in there dang it I just I
just junk Torbjorn he had the hit it out
of the park one and then Road hogs and
then those are the only two I saw you
put in that video so I'm not sure that's
everybody let's just corn and then may
may has okay this one cuz yeah road hog
definitely has one too you hopping oh
because of the okay it makes more sense
with the skin her new skin which is the
hoppin vampire yeah okay oh nice said he
got the colt is from his free Halloween
loop box no joke that's I've never had
that kind of luck than Roanoke has this
one right here
okay that's all right I need Zen and
Reapers as Kaiser Wolfe I do too those
are those are two characters I play why
don't you play a game of junky junk in
Stein's revenge and kind of tell me oh
wow let's go hard okay tell me what's
different if there is a difference in
this mode cuz like what Lucille Ball day
they minorly tweaked it and they had
like a a ranked version and that was
kind of about it
right I think think so I think it has
like balance changes or whatever at
least in the endless version of this
also keeps going there's an immersion
and then there's also Spore extra camp
is that you can actually play
[Music]
so okay we've gone through a couple
events now repeat events yeah with
summer games and this one
do you wish you got more out of the
events or are we just spoiled because we
got these the first time around because
to me it's like I kind of wish there was
a twist or something different yeah but
I also at the end of the day when you
think about it can't really complain
because these are free modes
yeah the free you get like this they
just keep giving those skins as well
it's not like no skins and then like a
repeat like that yeah there's always at
least something new in each of the
events dufus has nothing no as far as I
can tell no if there's any emotes that
you guys know about that we didn't
mention please give me a shout and chat
and I will correct correct ourselves
there you go so if you guys didn't know
this is like a wave based horde mode
essentially you have four characters you
can play as it's a Hanzo on a free and
soldier this is how it was last year as
well I think one of the differences is
Symmetra yeah I haven't played the the
regular one yet I've only done the
analyst one so far okay this is a
regular one yeah okay but at least in
that one they added Symetra to be like
the bad guys mix she's the summoner
I think it's so cool to just have like a
little event to celebrate even if we
don't as I mentioned get anything crazy
nice oh I think the uprising no uprising
via the anniversary of it alright yeah
they didn't have any like new modes or
anything but they had like some skins at
least which is pretty some were pretty
cool I know there are two new highlight
intros one for road hog and one for sure
be that would I know if this wasn't here
just email it say okay we can check that
out after thank you
and it's like one of those times where
like you get to bring out your Halloween
yeah the Reaper baby he's not the Sleepy
Hollow version he's a jocular what
happened to the tool we got merged like
nothing going on okay probably this guy
here I didn't actually kill a normal
what's up majestic Bob how are you doing
after we get through this juggen signs
we'll open some hot loot boxes and I
play that other endless mode see where
that takes us
[Music]
if you missed it earlier we did a shadow
skip get back here what you do more
quietly
I was pretty fun with the guys warp zone
and now we're doing some hot over watch
Halloween and Kara been babysit him
typical Hans L mean
oh that punch goes clutch yeah I
remember last year telling you I wish
they'd kind of like expanded this mode
even when we had it last year like you
know you progressed through this first
area then there's another area and you
slowly have like more and more different
enemies yeah oh yeah oh okay that works
oh where is he
Oh porky runs out of the darling
oh wow Joey what the clutch punching bet
I have a really bad habit I'm gonna play
this going like saving it for much too
long oh and I'm the only dealer for the
even in the freedom oh yeah for this one
let's see once you open it or once you
do the endless mode you actually a lot
because I would acknowledge that he
wishes he could play Lucio the wall for
the door like how much percent like 5% I
mean Hans are you little brat well you
know so be it you enjoy your life I
guess it could be worse it could be
again do you mean I'm just kidding
jeez all means are fine yeah exactly
it's just you're either a meme where
you're not
Jamison Jenkins Jamison Junkin Stein
imagine if you could shoot like that oh
my god okay oh you'll then get this oh
no reborn' good obviously you know who
the strong player is I guess they'd done
the loot boxes yet no we haven't
still got 52 to open
where is it
there's a reason I feel like I thought
you would have been done by now I'm not
sure how many waves we got in this world
or in this version I think still need oh
mercy still has a 13 out of 50 leaf
boxes left still knows in the otter
Symmetra skin
it's okay bait hope you got to have hope
you got to hold out hope you gonna have
some baby no those two are quality the
coolest-looking skins though yeah and
maybes Arya's as well because it's at
least unique question is how much will
tomorrow Hussein spell spend on getting
that sorriest okay here we go
so she's gonna res great and I wish kid
was really good though the soldier on
his own
Oh
I think it's arias games but I don't
player yeah that tends to happen I feel
like the game almost does some of that
stuff on purpose to get you to play
other characters because it's like oh
you have a really cool skin
why don't you play that hero now
talking out of my sight
let's go go to sleep just kidding I
thought that that road dog is pretty
good too I don't know about with a punch
oh nice maybe I need another hole we got
a Halloween box plan I'm sad that
Halloween and I are banner of the same
week and I would focus more on iron
banner Bob that's just me like I'm
destined to boy oh he's got the Skinner
yeah what it's because like to me you're
either gonna spend enough money to buy
the skins kind of right or I guess you
could play for playing takes a while
right so we got boxes unless you'd be a
week please I would just do your
challenges
get your loot boxes I'd be the fastest
yeah I mean if you only did your weekly
as it was just what three loop boxes a
week yeah in addition to whatever
experience you get I guess hey nope
still waiting for destiny to come out of
PC that's soon that's in 14 days
actually yeah two weeks we'll have a
launch stream I think we have a guest
coming in for the launch stream day but
I'm sure we'll do some more around that
as well on a scale of 64 to 297 because
random numbers how fun is this mode Joey
64 to 297 I'm gonna give it a hundred
and ninety six whatever all right so far
that counts mostly towards the higher
end of it I think it's all the tiber
what from yesterday I turned it off that
little box though no I got rid of it oh
there you go okay gonna open have you
ever thought what that blue box was
purple go yes so go oh my god what's
that so a victory pose that's cool all
right 52 to go well like I'm looking
these epochs duplicates nice today you
can't fire that at somebody with the
pumpkin was this one home it was cute no
one there all right
something good
usually it's about like I want to say
like three or four per 50 Bloody Mary
skins we'll see if he gets lucky what do
you want which one do you want he
already bought the one you yeah I know
so this one well we need to check that a
highlight intro thing later - yeah I
like these victory posies or nice
actually
it's his belly in yeah I think I want I
love all of them I think the honor one
okay I got all the new skins was then
and Symetra that's sorry at least got
enough coins to buy one soon usually
that's the case - yeah if you don't get
the stinking one usually have one
thought this again yeah I get duped
feels duped yeah all the ones really
know it's the pirate
hmm how's she holding that up that
doesn't make sense
Oh with the pumpkin I don't know strings
yeah look at dad sitting at the poor
Queen that's going right there yeah get
off my porch I'm gonna shoot you in the
face up what is your bad sure it's bad
feel so bad that could have been Azaria
no boo all right here we go we got one
in eight but it was not anyone all right
that's good I'll take gold right now
yeah thanks Reaper first loop box like a
Symetra feels good for you Noah that
luck though someone all set I think they
got zenyatta on their first seat yeah
that's so good I'm gonna open my first
later and just be filled with sadness
the game knows I haven't played in a
while
oh that was no those last years he had
like the skulls right on his yeah
all right
oh oh I didn't get the candy good job
there you go was that from last year
that was last year's okay does it
remember that video of that guy just
like I can report himself just giving
out candy to the opposing team that the
hawk okay yeah skin that's not the one
you want
oh we see this one here now you need to
get the skin that goes with the icon so
far so bad voice lines that's how they
get you man voice lines sprays
okay nice new McCree I like it free
replace the lifeguard for once beach bod
yeah man beach bod McCree so that took
like another sign to tell here here it
is actually I like this one the brain as
good as Cthulhu or occultist yeah
oh whoa this is cool take up me baby
don't be nice I love me a gummy bear
a big where's this one is both Cheers
yeah it's like we never left Joey still
there way 16 okay oops
zorax everyone opens box is different
some people like to click some people
just like over here and it feels good to
click this up like I've never actually
done spacebar though what's that
that old I was a pumpkin special I don't
have that I don't know I do
what's up Mason who's got the best new
skin I would argue using its Symmetra or
Zenyatta but that's me
Zaria is also a little close a close one
because she is very different today I
don't know if you have so those would be
my top 3 this time around cuz Reapers
even though it's kind of cool is like
it's still based so like him yeah you
know like the scary white man same with
McCree I mean he just has more of event
Helsing feel the glove things cool like
those three that I mentioned have the
biggest kind of like different look to
them have a weird OCD yeah it happens I
understand like I it the thing is I have
OCD but my OCD only clicks in like let's
say if I start cleaning then I can't
stop until it's like really clean right
but then if I don't start cleaning to
begin with I'm kind of just cool yeah
but once I start I can't that were under
this desk we're like messy and at some
point I was like I got to deal with it
and now it's like mostly better
you can't see it but it's okay so we got
like half of his boxes left I'll do one
more then we'll take a break
oh really what it you're not gonna okay
oh sure just go through the wall there
boxes even as watch each sing we
actually bought them blizzardon gifted
to us I feel like it's better look that
way if you buy your own I don't know
your luck so far has been pretty
mediocre yeah it's up to you if you want
to go through all of them or if you want
to just go half at they're not my boxes
so he's like oh you can pop one more and
then 53 oh here we go okay I'll stop
after this one sorry he's gone to nan
Halloween dude it's getting the choppa
yeah alright he's gonna play to try to
up his luck so we'll go to the well is
there anything else that you can get a
box from okay so if you beat that
I already did earlier it was a
deathmatch though cuz okay so for this
one you actually do get more characters
to play with so I think they added Genji
Torbjorn Zenyatta
towards you yeah that sounds like too
good and then oh widow
Green Green says opening loot boxes
gaming in 2017 yes we'll be talking
actually about loot boxes the goods the
bads all of that tomorrow in the lobby
that's one of the topics actually but to
overwatch his credit they've been doing
it since 2016 so you know there's
pioneer dude kind of psycho
I mean like paid for likes oh like for
everyone else yeah more mainstream kind
of mainstream and not like
like predatory almost like that since it
small depends man some of the stuff
coming out is not sick like as it is
right now some people are not happy with
a star card system which is how yeah
well I mean like a front to whatever
watch goes I think they've done a good
job at keeping it kind of like fair yeah
I I think that anytime you have pay to
look good yes I would say then it's fine
because it's totally up to the user to
then say hey I want to invest money to
get these skins or I can slowly get them
by playing the game yeah but it's not
gonna affect my gameplay that's the most
I think that's the most important part
of it is that it doesn't affect gameplay
once it starts becoming like that pay to
win yeah then it kind of gets sketchy
and I'd mentioned this before on other
streams and like other topics that like
another game that does that really well
as path of Exile they've been around
forever
they've always only done it's a
free-to-play game - yeah they've only
done pay to look good or like you know
just aesthetics it's all about
aesthetics it's not really about the
gameplay so that's the risk that we had
to watch out for or people need to watch
out for and it gets a little messy right
when you started having some beta win
dude he's so good in this mode he has a
turret he gets to shoot himself we don't
we do it because he can take care of the
wheels so this goes on forever yeah
technically all right it says way to of
12
so as you after you go after you get
past 12 that means like you you beat
pretty much like you'll end up with the
victory okay but you get anything extra
for going farther larger can increase
your team score I know like you know
climb to leave your boards or whatever
this again like so it does eventually
higher it does get harder so like they
have like multiple of the same enemies
on one slug you'll have like three
Reapers going all in one yeah tours just
cut a Halloween costume this year is
Santa Claus that's all this is the the
Viking
I don't know I don't think I don't think
it ever take this one off I just love it
too much side work man screw star cards
this is how you play 12 you are in the
food let's serve for you guys on we're
on America
Zarek's my sir do you know what I hate
and overwatch I'm so lucky on ps4 with
skins while PC I'm so lucky sounds about
right
Sam boy you can't play as any hero
there's just more heroes than there were
previously in the endless mode yeah two
of you are being one of them
widow was another one right yeah widows
in Yoda and ginji's our old boy can do
who needs Alma doesn't everybody need
armor go he's gonna put everywhere all
of them at once for science well too
late for that sorry I missed that Raul I
told you it was his skins he's gotten
three legendaries and about twenty he
said 2029 so I feel like you got one or
two more left with you of which I really
hope they're not good it's a tough one
Kaiser wolf I understand hey dewiness a
pretty tough one obviously most players
don't like it obviously depends it's
quite worse than a multiplayer game than
in a single-player game there's usually
single-player stuff is just like speed
of doing something yeah but uh yeah
touchy subject I don't know it's the
other subject is like even though like I
think there's less of it now but like
you know how like DLC is really pisses
people off and cry still does yeah I
don't know like I think if I like the
game enough and they were giving me new
content and it was like good content I
don't mind paying fifteen to twenty
dollars I guess but that's me because I
know I'll get my value out of it like
yeah I like destiny too like I know I'll
get the value out of that deal see for
myself now that it's not everybody knows
but any person who's the difference
between like giving them extra content
as opposed to content that should have
been in theaters
yeah but technically I don't wanna play
devil's advocate on that statement but
you know the argument is that was it
supposed to be in and they cut it you
don't I mean so we'll leave that's the
kind of stuff for the loggers we'll
leave that kind of a conversation in the
lobby we're here playing the
professional yeah we're here just
playing some hot over watch Halloween
terror event which is back if you didn't
know already
Oh does he have the Cthulhu no yeah yeah
the feral what a basic basic day one
that's a good one though no for me than
yatta its Nutcracker or that Cthulhu one
that cultists one that's it like I've
always have my old song deck sorry world
man asking which to overwatch arrows
would be the most awkward in a room
together
get back here trying to sing
we're like polar opposites maybe Roadhog
and Reinhart and that'd be awkward
Road Dogg doesn't really talk right so
does sometimes yeah but then that would
be like road hog would be pretty awkward
with anyone except for a junk rat or
anyone that doesn't have like a huge
personality yes yeah uh-huh
we're seeing tracer huh
yeah I don't know why they thought
Gerber with the okay he's fine I know I
know I like him too as a character Oh to
watch kind of cool I like that yeah he
gets his okay yeah well cuz your turn is
literally already like like all these
zombies sucking non-stop I mean it's
like tower defense yeah no I want it to
be more like cyber defense but like
that's why I think that I don't know he
feels kind of broken Saint what that get
fashion was in the game or in this mode
rather sorry well he wasn't the uprising
event they have or taint dude this
symmetric skin is so damn lit yeah
pretty lit she finally got I mean as I
mentioned she had some good ones but man
this is her first like really yeah like
oh good one the one that like you have
to like get I feel like for me like the
Rhinehart one for me that I had to have
was the the anime one which one the one
from good guy starts with the G you know
when they when the castle level came out
oh yeah I had to have it like I
immediately spent gold
I didn't even wait it's kind of like
your Zarya situation yeah I'm like dude
it's too sick it's it's literal animal
Rinehart grass is going to somebody
oh we are not losing this no
si quieren Singh I can't wait for evil
within this Friday even with the two
that is there's actually so interesting
thing is that we can the game is being
streamed by some people right now we're
gonna stream it tomorrow actually cyborg
man if you want to come back in tune and
for that it'll be after the Logies but
will be prior streaming some people
within to tomorrow
I think we're allowed to show like verse
six chapters or something like that I'm
not sure how many chapters are but that
should be grateful this joke rat is why
spy why somebody killed junk rat last
time first yeah that's a very good idea
because just because you're gonna wipe
here look at the doors health I'm okay I
feel like onna would be better than
zenyatta onna can heal multiple people
get jokin Stein oh okay fine I guess I
will take care of him and outside of
like Zenyatta is uh okay you know and
his alt oh she's back dragon lady
Daenerys
rip come on boy it was going fine all
the way Reinhardt is anime double stream
tomorrow - yeah probably good it's been
a crazy week then I'm gonna force my way
into destiny to you later this week
because I haven't I'm supposed to be
playing destiny too today but you know
over watch him shadow ward or shadow for
ward or that's why he's not healing man
doesn't have to heal he killed ninety
five six turret kills hundred eighty are
166 turret kills 180 total alright go
for some more boxes I'm feeling it I'm
feeling another feeling it man I'm
feeling another legendary 25 boxes ago
huh
the guy is the worst healer Blizzard
continues its tradition of hating monks
in all their games didn't really need a
heal as a monk and III bang
go get my Ingram stay well you know if I
could have streamed I probably would
have got some engrams ready which
difficulty was that that's hard it was
hard maybe if you had a slightly better
team comp it would have been me yeah
although I'm not very good Torrey born I
just was fine I thought it was fine
there's nobody is taking care of man
yeah nobody nobody had range to kill
that's what you probably want that Hanzo
or Widow to deal with that
hi Hanzo more than widow man sure that's
a weird what happened here Frankenstein
I guess it doesn't do it it just says it
I'm basic okay I could I had a knife
fall in grandma yeah I could have didn't
happen though I'm probably only gonna
are you guys gonna seeing the Leviathan
procedures probably not Ricky not
against our proper I might do it on my
own time legendary oh sweet ah that's a
good one that's a good one not the one
that I wear man I get to see it I get to
see it man I get to live vicariously
through you I think that's why people
like watching other people do loop
Paco's I mean either enjoy the salt or
you know enjoy the hype but in terms of
the procedure aid Ricky if I do it it'll
be on my own time at home but if that's
next week obviously cuz it got pushed
so probably doing Ironman oh there's
bastions from last year yeah might be
some iron banner tonight though Ricky
want to come watch us get work I might
do normal rage philanthropy the drop
rates don't seem good this time around
I'm going to spend 70 bucks on lupus
again I know it come on pal Anthony
wants you to play the game philanthropy
is been djenka
guys don't know who Ben Gingka is one of
our fellow employees here at games by hi
hi hi hello King monkey gaming
all right what are we at like nine boxes
Oh 13 okay we still got I think you're
gonna get one more one more
so I'm hoping you get honor that's my
hope I'm hoping for one more for you
getting a lot of Dubes here no it's not
gonna be a take Harry Ricky it's just
gonna be my normal do man I still want
to have the Zen skin you can do it BAM
boy
I believe I call it at the 10th loot box
you get a legendary all right Xerox
Meister's right or this is a good spray
it's like swinging the are you both
Asian yes roughly we're both Asian what
are you actually are you just Chinese
yes 100% 100% I mean I'm sure there's
like yeah go down my tree couple hundred
just like me saying like I'm 50%
Singaporean cuz my dad is but then like
it does that really count because
ultimately I'm still trying anyway
semantics 300 gear drop in our Banana
Nut that I've seen gube I think an
exotic Engram but I haven't seen actual
IB gear drops though well that's it kind
of cool
you have to get them from coins which is
it's not that fast not that that Oh
Chinese I'll take it that sucks at least
now the the emote makes more you get a
legendary in the next box I will donated
$1 where's our $1 were you gonna call me
- where's our $1 mystical meme I don't
think you're gonna get another one I
could be wrong though
we add law to everything with you
yeah Maia's man I agree vain hope it was
definitely Zenyatta and Symetra where
they are the goatees with Azaria being a
coaster alright six more boxes what's up
so cool 64 glad we got a new viewer glad
you could tune us tune in with us good
looking pretty grim as as repo a I don't
know man so you got three new ones
that's b3 yeah McCree yeah May and
Zenyatta Jana yeah that's three it's
only three well you got five total
because he got the oh he's gone six
three were Halloween three were
Halloween three were normal he's he's
definitely screwed here party's over
he's definitely screwed here he's it's
it's never know you get a double
legendary right here
Oh another one though gold that's okay
actually I'm off to I'm back up to 8,000
I would take that over some of those
skins you don't want your definitely
skewed here I just need to keep with the
trend
we can at least buy it yeah it's a good
buy this about your skin so you got one
of the two good ones and you bought the
other one so technically you have three
all three of the good ones and don't
have 14 old is gold if I'm not gonna buy
anything right yeah so all right that
was it that's fine so I guess that's
pretty good though
I feel like in 53 ish boxes he got six
legendary skins that's pretty Ana
legendary gold yeah so he got three new
ones and three old ones I think that
that's not bad
and now granted you didn't get the ones
you wanted which is Ana oh yeah you want
Ana - yeah so are you gonna buy Ana and
Samara I'll probably buy on a if maybe
like sooner that is so creepy by the way
I really what's up the channel of edited
videos I hope you edit your own videos
and then I'll probably go too much or
maybe near the end because I don't
really play her that much
ciarán r1 is it worth it to jump out of
bed to open some loot boxes I mean if
you want this hot Oh dragon Symetra or
uh cultists I keep water calm Cthulhu
Zenyatta
cult is Zenyatta wait wait where are
those two player intros what did I say
they were again Oh hope says I'll trade
you Anna for his end
if only you could do that no oh my god I
think he's the only highlight intro that
I saw I don't think anyone else has it I
went through all of them in the video
alright you wanna hop in a way are you
buying anything no right you know PI
wait oh wait oh well yeah at this point
pirate Anna is so good says Ben Janka
it's pretty good
well we can get another win okay get a
win then Oh a normal win a normal game
win is what you're saying right like a
non endless mode either one oh you know
one game because of the the weeklies I
got normal gaming Kenji was a lamer this
time he got nothing I mean he got dragon
Symetra supposed to be a succubus no
it's very clear she had succubus last
year didn't she who symmetric
no she had vampire 1 this was a fire my
bad but no no it's clearly she's a dress
it says dragon and her gun is also like
insane oh you gotta go cultist Zegna do
this better goob
I want a dragon thing scan for all the
heroes that would be pretty cool jour it
I feel like Reinhart kind of has won
that red that red armor is pretty crazy
the only looking one mask like has like
a zombie slayer said and November 1st
that's a new meta that's a new junk rat
meta to Mueller comp baby your DPS
anyway ok yeah your DV yes you don't
snipe the junk in Stein man I was doing
that earlier put your heel or wand the
tank or whoever does close
jenji because he's probably take damage
anything you just you just sniper that's
good cuz like I can be all over here oh
he got out of bed and got honor I don't
know I don't know if CR on r1 is
trolling but even if he's not that like
at least I know he's watching and that
is like that's how code though yeah
that's how it go is truly though Joey
it's like the skins you want the most
you usually maybe get one openness but
usually you don't yeah and then you get
skins for other characters and then
you're like okay I have enough gold so I
guess I'll go buy the one I want do you
get more loot boxes for a higher
difficulty no Harvey Miller he gets him
off wins so what's up mini panda hello
put up a hand I'll put up a hand
I think having that discord or bindus
yeah just here though oh yeah give them
the boot give them the squid boot Jeff
Kaplan is watching the stream and
trolling I wish are the Lord and Savior
Jeff Kaplan we're in here hi Jeff yeah
remember that one stream where I put
like more woods yeah okay I forget
that's a great shame
that was an uprising one right I think
somebody had those yeah like please save
us Jeff give us your power war over
watching war I think he says his update
fringes in two minutes sounds good
sounds great have fun
hopefully you have all the luck with
your crates some people I I'm always
shocked by the people that open one
crate and get like legendaries it's like
my one friend I see every time he opens
his first free box and it's always a
legendary and it's a good one it's
usually a good one it's like man why
don't I have that kind of luck some BS
man yup nah man I just got symmetric new
skin and zanna's new skin on ps4
I'll probably get [ __ ] on PC well why
did you open it one ps4 first also good
on you for playing on both platforms I
guess you must just have a split group
of friends they're good that's like it
kind of weird right to play mouse
keyboard together like older it's a very
different I don't know anyone who's like
who actually plays on folks
ciarán basically came to ask if cheese
should open he or she should open loop
boxes got on and it's now like see you
later have a good tree I hope you get on
a later Oh cats and have a good day
thanks for tuning in
get him no he said something else oh he
said something else I couldn't hear it
though
I'm so sorry okay we're gonna have
experience in like a different like okay
my B might be chat I totally botched
that when he gets super I'll make sure
to turn it up and I promise not to say
anything that is cool though yeah that's
like Mercy's revive yeah I was uh I was
thinking about the set when I went to go
get lunch about what sorry is oh I was
like I will rock on her shirts is like
let's get physical do you think that
they all have different voice lines
though I mean like I wouldn't put it
past blizzard to have subtle touches
like that play yeah it's only usually
only for a couple of them hoody I think
this is who do you think not how do you
think I should mean McCree or zenyatta
very different classes if you have
really good accuracy McCrea is a very
deadly offensive character real talk I'm
terrible with bolts okay you just tell
me experience nothingness is on the next
boss I guess runway 5 right now but is
he a pirate who benefits pirate honor
and killing you or or the tire yeah okay
I'll use it now what oh no someone else
like said something at the scene it was
like so listen only the tire started
coming out a witness I did he say like
nothing was it nothing this maybe it was
nothing that was that was muddled yeah I
know
we'll get it again though but it could
be what mr. Smith said which is nothing
this it kind of did sound like that but
because of the tire or whatever it was
it definitely stopped us from hearing
what we knew going to corner do you
think she said that or do you think that
just like in the later voice line yeah
she might
you should I get my golden gun towards
ru I'm a career soldier but why why me
that's Joey in tomorrow if I tell you
two guys are yeah yeah that's tough it's
probably like whoever you play the most
but if you play those three alive okay
I'll go into a corner I know saria's new
gun because of her skin on gold looks
really good alright are you doing it
next time alright go run off in the
corner yeah someone else ate the
experience nothing else that's dinosaur
no it's fine even though he pops alt and
we listen to it on her own
you don't wanna honestly still work out
because confirmed that's pretty cool
thank you uh see the few people dinosaur
man and mr. Smith I think that said
experience okay so that I didn't believe
you right here we got two roads to grow
dogs so imagine if they could heal oh
they can though okay can they do the
drink yeah they can still do the uh get
rid of artillery fire
the two healer Mehta is not looking so
hot right now we don't have enough dps
oh my god
now tell the other one is low there you
go forever
headshot dings yeah it cuz she says that
when she does it all right so huh Ricky
says experience nothingness and yada
husband I'm spending too much time with
the reaper
get the which okay focus fire than
pretty good
everyone keeps waking up I know it's
like can't help it
I was joking son here I think you gotta
focus joking aside dad you might be
thinking I've got the soldier on okay
playing the objective no Jeeves come on
candy
you're like let me kill what I know I
can kill oh my god stop it
Reapers out to you by the way oh he's
using news this is getting real sketch
okay okay we're on your good one way out
wrong we've nine dragon 17550 double
Reaper I love it three PDB why to get it
in there they experience nothing
nice story house oh it's okay well
you're on wave 10 to 12 you died so
maybe the two healer Mehta didn't work I
mean I still feel like we're a little
bit low on videos just because like last
time no one was on but you surviving
this is looking real tranquility I mean
nothingness nothingness not tranquil
okay guys just careful oh there's
another summoner okay
ah damaged I'd do a daughter
yeah like rays I read no no not me yeah
getting that
Bulger he'll best heels
okay all right Joe still lives to live
here
successful
oh it is that's just so let's company so
that was that was a way he respected
looking
I'm low on health
you bought me with it left side in mini
whelps right side all right one junk
inside down
for example the monster
we got a witch Oh No Oh five life on now
not like this Joey we wanted a box no no
we can make it we can make it
Viper don't die oh god he's still alive
oh you're so dead on a please oh the
junk - junk inside 15 seconds if you
live does that kind of the win or do you
have to clear it all I think you have to
just live okay we're good one second two
seconds yeah bonus wave does that mean
you want so so you win but you still
keep going so I can prove your score Oh
never yeah okay that we did it fine box
guys gonna cover other Halloween events
you know their game sure destiny I'm not
sure what other games are gonna have
Halloween events but we'll check about
me sons on what it is there's a hedgehog
nice play of the game hey that's what
you guys do you just destroy a lane
what's up ascetic cat what's up
encrypted boy how are you doing
you have the Viking and an skin this is
overwatch gamers I don't know what the
end and new stars with it
alright let's get lucky with this crate
you ready for a hot legendary 8,800
that's how much you had like when you
started today uh what do you wanna do we
can do like one more thing it's totally
up to you
what would be what do you want to do I
kind of want to go through just quick
play with okay with the Zarya skin do it
so good are we doing a normal quick play
match with that
Zaria skin let's get physical' it's like
yeah this is her best skin I mean
compared to something like yes cyberguy
which I always like putting on just for
the lols you would then there's this one
which is actually really good I like
that one I like that one this is so
different but I'm into Mecca stuff so
that makes sense no we don't have the
symmetric skin but he has enough gold to
buy it and ans human what Halloween
skins do you have this is one of them
Shea Louden or Loden
show him some more we also got McCree
got that McCree health Van Helsing and
then we got May so I get corns no you
didn't you got me the vampire
essentially let me do the hopping
vampire she's not as like pale as she
needs to be yeah anyways you got one
more which was in yatta the cultist
which is what we were playing what that
one's so good man
big this is ie in his chest oh man
that's a good I don't know if I have
3,000 gold man I really hope I have
3,000 gold suck it just by Zenyatta what
are those damn never seen so much makeup
on Zarya weird actually
like that street style ooh she's a
stylist gigantic headband let's get
physical physical did you get the
vampire skin yes right which law
technically no we didn't get Dracula
which is Reaper Symetra has like a
vampire one from yeah Steven I think the
real good ones are the symmetric dragon
looks crazy
holy crap I actually got something good
on PC I got Zhen and Anna's pretty good
I'm not the one that Joey wants the most
yeah like gold gun that's what you spent
it on huh yeah that you're only golden
gun yeah I mean it thanks
I think last season I didn't play that
much competitive so I'm getting main
points for it but I think I should have
enough fur and another one this season
I'm not sure who's by whose to buy
I haven't played competitive at all just
get your did not do template matches I'm
gonna ruin the game for me and yes quick
play still exists but it's not the same
they're less more tests
he doesn't have which mercy when things
are dying next level stretch trying to
lob damage over
I keep forgetting that she's different
and she has rockets yeah she was Rockets
she can she can uh shoot her Wow
no remember she was different right why
are we all dead
thank you
yeah at 69 comp point I know that sure
enough food Zara once I was him claim
agree maybe maybe I claim agree you
later maybe Daria is his go-to though
we spent 3000 coins let the man play
what you want done oh good night
now let me see if her parole sounds
different
okay well you're closed yeah we'll get
it awesome for the end another match
just told me we knew I try to rise the
audio here too in case she says
hello
Oh
yeah the double-double mine's better
I want the Cthulhu skin yeah he got it
here we got it
that hot cultists
but it was a game
not really well yeah we'll have a new
team I'm not sure three guys there okay
you gotta win stay on now Vic cheese
someone says Gangji I cares the worst
skins in the game ah rated skin I bought
that one too yeah Anthony I mean writer
oh yeah common writer people
Oh travel
you got five minutes a day there's a lot
of time a lot
this is briefly trying to figure out
what he's doing all right where do I go
I once I am someone said the Azaria has
the same clothes almost so so oh yeah
girls like hey can I borrow those and
trying to do a Halloween costume
okay
Oh Beachbody with me that turret whoops
the audio is probably really loud in
Italy turn that down
good job did you kill it oh you killed
it okay good
Oh Reaper getting it done oh he's
dissolved for one person no that's
wash res the bastion alright
I
it's so annoying
see those rocket barrage okay you have
ulti Oh what killed me all the farm once
you get here that game-changing switch
should I switch did we have well you
could if you want death notice her range
attack is pink shoes that's the trail
let's hear the trails I think maybe
oh oh she got she got tired yeah the
tires
Oh someone got clear that Bastian oh no
we're not no we're not he's really low
though I know he's not not anymore gabe
newell's in the chat oh hey
there you go Oh fine
they drop the beat
where's the Justice raining oh and we're
taking the objective Wow opposed that
was good Joey I feel like it's not gonna
get better than that let's watch to play
the game
okay look at the Reaper Oh guess we
can't blame him for switching the bat
like a five players nice all right there
you go let's end with that thank you
guys all for tuning in as mentioned we
opened like 50 crates we got or 50 loot
boxes joy we got six legendary skins
three of which were new including that
beautiful tentacle de monster right
there
thanks for playing Joey yeah thank you
for having me yeah it was pretty fun day
if you missed it earlier we had a shadow
of war middle of Middle Earth shadow of
war stream you can check that out that's
Bo deed on the youtubes and GameSpot of
course tomorrow we have the lobby
well actually we talking about loot
boxes the good and the bad of the loot
box is a 20-17 know some other fun
topics possibly even an evil within to
stream tomorrow after the lobby as well
so until then until next time I hope you
guys all have a wonderful Tuesday and
see you guys next time bye